تقدمت القوات الفرنسيه باتجاه شمال مالي
فيما استجابت عده دول الى طلب باريس وقاده
دول غرب افريقيا من اجل زياده المساعده
الدوليه للعمليه العسكريه الجاريه هناك
وكانت باريس اعلنت ان قواتها ستبقى في
مالي الى حين ما وصفته بدحر
الارهاب
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في عنوانين
رئيسيين ما مدى نجاعه الاستمرار في
استخدام القوه العسكريه وسيله وحيده
للتعاطي مع الوضع في مالي وما هو المطلوب
حتى لا يتحول هذا النزاع الى مهدد حقيقي
لاستقرار مالي والدول المحيطه
بها
فيما بدا اهتماما فرنسيا على اعلى
المستويات بالعمليات العسكريه التي تجري
في مالي قال وزير الدفاع الفرنسي ان
مقاتلات بلاده تقصف اهدافا في مدينتي جاو
وتمبكتو شمالي مالي بعد ورود انباء عن
تقدم رتل من القوات الفرنسيه باتجاه شمال
البلاد الذي يسيطر عليه الاسلاميون منذ
عده اشهر وبينما حدد وزير الدفاع الفرنسي
الهدف من العمليات التي تخوضها قواته هناك
بانه عاده السيطره على كامل الاراضي
الماليه كانت فرنسا قد اكدت على لسان
رئيسها انها لن تغادر الاراضي الماليه قبل
القضاء على الارهابيين على حد قول
رئيسها مالي البلد الغارق في فقره
وصراعاته السياسيه وانقلابات العسكريه كرس
بفعل العمليه الفرنسيه الجاريه فيه موقعه
مركزا لرهانات محليه واقليميه ودوليه واقع
بدا جليا في قمه ابيدجان التي تداعت لها
قيادات مجموعه دول غرب افريقيا المعروفه
بالاكوا وفي الجهود الفرنسيه الحثيثه لحشد
الدعم الاقليمي والعربي والغربي لحمله
باريس العسكريه التي طوت اسبوعها الثاني
الجزائر التي شرعت تدفع في عين اميناس
نصيبها من كلفه الحرب على المسلحين
الاسلاميين في مالي تلقت دعوه من الرئيس
الفرنسي فرانسوا اولاند لمساهمته اكبر في
حل الازمه في منطقه الساحل في م قبل تحمس
اغلب اعضاء الايكواس ابدت الجزائر خشيتها
مرارا من ان اي مغامره عسكريه في مالي قد
تقود المنطقه برمتها الى كابوس امني
وانساني يفوق طاقتها مفضله التريث والبحث
في حلول تفاوضيه تقود الى عزل القاعديين
عن غيرهم من حركات التمرد في شمال ووسط
مالي لم تتق باريس صبرا وهي ترى المسلحين
الاسلاميين يقتربون ببطء من العاصمه
الماليه باماكو يكادون يجهزون على دوله
نخرها الفساد السياسي والعسكري لعقود
فعمدت الى خطوه بدت استباقيه لم تجد
الجزائر حيالها سوى فتح مجالها للمقاتلات
الفرنسيه خاصه وان جهودها التفاوضيه مع
بعض الجماعات شمال مالي اصيبت بنكسه اثر
توجه حركه انصار الدين وغيرها للسيطره على
مدن استراتيجيه في البلاد اندفاع فرنسي
اضعف من زخمه فتور اوروبي امريكي تساوره
شكوك في نجاعه العمل العس
قابله تحفظ جزائري هش حكمته قراءه تتوجس
من قياده فرنسيه لمجهود ما يعرف بمقاومه
الارهاب في منطقه الساحل الافريقي الجزائر
صاحبه الباع والذراع في مقارعه الجماعات
الاسلاميه المسلحه بقيت عصيه على محاولات
احتواء لخبرتها الواسعه التي اكتسبتها من
الايام العصيبه للحرب الاهليه صدرت عن
الامريكيين وعدد من الدول الغربيه تتقدمها
فرنسا بما لها من صالحه استراتيجيه
تاريخيه في المنطقه تغيرت المعادله وبات
الاحجام والاقدام خيارين احلاهما
مر لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من باريس
الدكتور حسني عبيدي مدير مركز الدراسات
والابحاث حول العالم العربي في جنف واستاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعتي باريس وجنيف
ومن واكش معنا المحلل السياسي الحسين ولد
مدو نبدا معك دكتور حسني ونسال حول هذا
التصريح الاخير للرئيس الفرنسي فرانسوا
اولاند ان التدخل في مالي سيستغرق الوقت
الضروري لذلك هل تملك فعلا فرنسا ادوات
هذه السياسه هي التي هرولت ومنذ اول يوم
لطلب المساعده الماليه واللوجستيه من عديد
الدول التصريح الاخير للرئيس الفرنسي يكشف
بان باريس اصبحت مقنعه الان بان التدخل
فقط من خلال ضربات جويه لن يؤدي الى نتيجه
ايجابيه كما كانت تتمناه منذ البدايه وانه
لابد من تدخل عسكري سواء بري او بطلب
مساعدات اقليميه ومساعدات دوليه هل فرنسا
لديها القدره على الاستمار اعتقد انه نفس
فرنسا العسكري لا يمكن ان يطول خاصه اذا
كان هناك التزام للقوات على الارض وفي
اطار هذا التردد الاوروبي لحد الساعه
التردد لوجست يعني الان المساعده لوجستيك
او او ماديه لم تصل الى حد فعلا المساعده
العسكريه وباريس تعي اخيرا بان كذلك
القوات الافريقيه ليست بتلك القدره التي
يمكن فعلا ان تقوم بالمقاول للدور الفرنسي
في المنطقه ولذلك فرنسا الان فعلا تبحث
على ليس مخرج وانما على حلول اخرى على
مسارات اخرى من اجل مساعدتها في الاستمرار
باعتبار ان الضربات الجويه لن تكفي وحدها
لتامين واستقرار مالي اضف الى ذلك عمليه
الاستمرار في حاله في حاله نجاح دحر
التنظيمات المسلحه من المدن التي كانت
تسيطر عليها اذا فرنسا وفق الدكتور حسني
العبيدي تبحث عن مسارات وطرق اخرى لهذا
التدخل لعل التدخل جويا لم يعد مجديا كما
رصد الدكتور حسين العبيدي ربما هي تريد
تدخلا بريا اتحول السيد الحسين ولد مدو
الى اي مدى تدخل بري جوي استعدادات
لوجستيه وماليه قد تمد بها فرنسا وحدها
والتدخل العسكري وحده كفيل فعلا بان ينهي
الموضوع في
مالي اعتقد بان ثمه مساله متدرجه اساسا
الفرنسيون حينما اعلنوا بانهم لن يدخلوا
الاراضي الماليه ولن يحاربوا على الطريقه
البريه بالنسبه لهذه الجماعات المسلحه في
شمال مالي كانوا يهدفون من وراء ذلك الى
مجرد عمليه تسويق والحقيقه ان الفرنسيين
يعرفون بان اقامتهم في مالي ستطول وبان
الضرائب التي ستنجر عن هذه الحرب ايضا
ستكون باهظه سواء على مستوى فرنسا وعلى
مستوى عمليه استقطاب المالي لتمويل هذه
الحرب فضلا عن انه لا يمكن كثيرا التعويل
من الناحيه اللوجستيه وم الناحيه الماليه
على تلك القوات التي ستوفرها منظمه غرب
افريقيا بصفه عامه سيما وان اخر
اجتماعاتها كان قد دعت مجلس الامن الى
ضروره المساعده في عمليه الانتشار فما
بالك بعمليه الاستعداد والدخول في الناحيه
العمليه لذلك ستواجه فرنسا اشكالات كبيره
سواء على مستوى تعبيه الموارد الماليه
وحتى البشر
في ظل لا اقول ولا اسميه تقاعس اوروبيا
لانني اعتقد بان الاوروبيين سيكونون
وكانوا بالفعل الى جانب فرنسا وكذلك
الامريكيين ولكن طبيعه الحرب ونوعيه
الشريك على الاقل في هذه الحرب ستضطر
فرنسا الى المزيد من بحث الخيارات
المتعدده سماما اننا امام مواجهه عصابات
لا تبدو في طبيعه الجيوش النظاميه وهو ما
يتطلب نوعا من تعضيد الجهود الفرنسيه
بمراعاه الابعاد الداخليه سواء في المحيط
الصحراوي القاحل او سواء ايضا بطبيعه حرب
الع الاصابات التي في دعوتها العالميه
التي تقوم عليها القاعده واخواتها في شمال
مالي ايضا تتعاطى بطريقه عالميه في ردود
الفعل ولا تواجه الجيش الفرنسيه في السماء
الماليه بقدر ما تواجه ارتكاسات وردات
فعله فضلا عن المواطني هذه الدول الغربيه
في البلدان الاخرى كما حدث في الجزائر
مؤخرا اذا وفقا للسيد حسين ولد مد على
فرنسا البحث عن خيارات اخرى الكتور حسني
هل تعتقد ان من بين هذه الخيارات التي
ستلج اليها فرنسا ربما بعد مده ومضطره
ايضا
التفاوض يعني فرنسا قبل كل شيء تخشى ان
تكون هناك خسائر في الارواح وكما تعلمين
التقلب في الراي العام ممكن جدا بين لحظه
وا اخرى اذا كانت تمت فعلا خسائر في
الجنود الفرنسيين ولذلك هي تعمل من اجل ان
لا تكون المده طويله في نفس الوقت تريد ان
تحضر الراي العام ولذلك جاء هذا الت تصريح
الرئيس
الرئيس الفرنسي فرانسوا هولاند الى من
يمكن ان تتجه يعني فرنسا للاسف لم تستغيب
بما فيه الكفايه الى ما قاله الممثل
الامين العام لمنطقه الساحل السيد رومان
برودي الذي قال بانه يجب عدم التسرع في
عمليه لم يتم التحضير لها جيدا ولا بد
العمل على مسارات اخرى الجمع بين كما كما
سما هو بين العمل الدبلوماسي والتفاوض
وكذلك القوه العسكريه كقوه عمليه غط وليس
كخيار اولي استراتيجي دكتور حسني رد
الفرنسيون على هذه النقطه المتعلقه
بالتسرع بانهم كانوا مضطرين الى ذلك والا
لما كان يوجد الان على الخارطه
مالي صحيح لكن كانت هناك يعني خيارات اخرى
مثلا القيام منذ فتره لانه نحن نعلم جيدا
بان بان شمال مالي همش وكذلك كان هناك
غياب
لهذا للنظام للسلطه انه الجيش اصبح جيشا
انقلابيا فبدل مثلا القيام بعمل كدعم
للجيش قدرات الجيش المالي ربما كذلك فصل
الجماعات المسلحه ما بينها وبين الاهالي
اي كانت هناك عمليات استباقيه يمكن ان
تبدا قبل البدا في عمليه عسكريه ستضع
الجميع امام مازق اما ان تمشي مع فرنسا او
ربما ستسمى بانها لا تريد مساعده فرنسا في
محاربه الارهاب وهو نفس المازق او لنقل
الفخ الذي نصب للجزائر التي كانت منذ
سنوات تنادي بحرب دولي على الارهاب اليوم
هناك تصويت مجلس الامن على قرار 2058
وبالتالي بدا من الصعب على الجزائر على
دول اخرى ان لا ان لا تتفق او ان لا تصير
على الاقل الموقف الفرنسي في محاربه
الارهاب وفي وقف زحف التنظيمات المسلحه
لكن مره اخرى هل فرنسا لديها القدره على
الاستمرار في عمليه ستطول و وسما تصل الى
مناطق اخرى اعتقد الاجابه لا ولذلك هناك
فعلا قلق داخل هنا الاوساط الفرنسيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي غائب تماما هناك شر
الكبير ربما عمليه عنا مناص ساعدت ساعدت
الحكومه الفرنسيه فيان تقول بان حربها على
الارهاب او حربها في مالي ليست حرب
افريقيه ليست حرب الوصايه ليست حرب الدوله
المستعمره وانما هي حرب ضد الارهاب الدولي
ودليل ما وقع ل رهائن الدول الاوروبيه نعم
دكتور حسني وقد اشرت الى حادثه عين اميناس
واشرت ايضا الى الفخ الذي نصب للجزائر في
الواقع كثيرون يشاطرون الراي وتحول بهذه
الفكره لسيد الحسين ولد مدو هل جرت
الجزائر فعلا الى هذه الحرب جرا خاصه وان
استحضرنا اخر تصريح الليله فقط لوزير
الدفاع الفرنسي جون ايف لودون الذي قال
بان ما حدث في عين من الناس هو في الواقع
عمل حربي الى اي مدى باعتقادك الجزائر جرت
الى هذا الموضوع وهل باتت فعلا جزءا منه
هو وبكل تاكيد بان العمليه التي قامت بها
الجماعات المسلحه في عنام الناس اكدت على
الاقل بالنسبه للطرح الفرنسي نوعا ما هذه
الوجاهه التي كان يتقدم بها فرانسوا
هولاند الى كل مخاطبيه والى كل شركائه بان
الحدث جلل وبان الارهاب تحد دولي ويتعين
على المنظومه الدوليه ان تواجهها صحيح
كذلك ان الموقف الجزائري تغير مؤخرا ونحن
نعرف بان الجزائر عاده سواء بحكم سياقها
الحالي او بحكم تراثها التاريخي مفرطه
الحساسيه حيال التدخل الفرنسي وحيال
المشاركه في الحروب وفي لحظه وبعد بعد من
المفاوضات سيما وانها كانت من اول الداعين
الى ضروره اتاحه الفرصه للمزيد من الحوار
بين الفرقاء الماليين وبين الحكومه
الماليه من اجل تحييد الجماعات الاكثر
تجذراً الاختلاف الكبير على الاقل فيما
يعرف بطريقه قاتل لكن الى اي مدى باعتقاد
سيد حسين الى اي مدى باعتقادك الجزائر
ستنخفض في هذه
العمليه العسكريه في مالي والجميع يعلم
بان ربما الجزائر ترفض تماما التدخل خارج
حدودها عسكريا هل ربما سنشهد تفاوضا مع
جماعه انصار الدين التفاوض الذي ليس غريبا
عليها هي كانت تجري تفاوضا مع هذه الجماعه
قبل العمليه العسكريه بقليل فقط بكل تاكيد
نعتقد بان الجزائر وليبيا كانت الراعيين
الاساسيتين على الاقل طلال العقود الماضيه
للقضيه الازواديه سواء في محاوله ايجاد
حلول تضمن تجاوز مراحل الغبن ومراحل الظلم
والقهر الذي ظلت تعاني منه هذه المنطقه
بصفه عامه قبل ان يتسلل الى هذه المنطقه
بعض من المجموعات التي شعلت المطالب
والمغالطات في هذه المنطقه شعلتها تختلط
ببعد كوني وبعد دولي يرتبط بمواجهه
الجماعات المسلحه واعتقد بان الجزائري دور
في هذه المرحله ليس فقط في دعم المجهود
الدولي الهادف الى عمليه تحييد المجموعات
المسلحه وانما كذلك في محاوله تحييد
السكان الاصليين والحركات الاكثر
تجذراً عملي التدخل دون تشاور مع مختلف
الشركاء المحليين وهو ما عقد الوضع وبرر
لفرنسا عمليه التدخل المباشر تحت ذريعه
امكانيه مهاجمه بمكو لاحقا سنعود حتما الى
هذه النقطه المهمه التي اشرت اليها لكن
لعل السؤال ايضا الذي سنطرح بعد الفاصل
كيف يمكن ضمان عدم تحول العمليات العسكريه
في مالي الى حرب مفتوحه تهدد مالي وحتى
جيران مالي نواصل النقاش بعد فاصل
قصير
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش تداعيات استمرار التدخل
العسكري الفرنسي في مالي على استقرار
المنطقه قبل الفاصل كنا نتحدث عن مجموعه
او جماعه انصار الدين اتحول بسؤال
الاندكتور حسني العبيدي هذه الجماعه التي
سبق وان تفاوضت الجزائر معها الى اي مدى
فعلا يمكن الوثوق بها خاصه اذا ما
استحضرنا ما حدث ربما قبل سماح الجزائر
بفتح مجالها العسكري من ان هذه
الجماعه في نفس الوقت التي كانت تفاوض مع
الجزائر ربما تقدمت عسكريا الى بعض
المناطق في مالي ومن هنا السؤال الى اي
مدى فعلا يمكن الوثوق باي تفاوض مع هذه
الجماعه يعني انا لا استبعد ان تكون جماعه
انصار الدين يعني منقسمه على نفسها وان
كان هناك فعلا تيار يريد التفاوض بل ذهب
بعيدا في عمليه التفاوض مع الجزائر
باعتبار ان الجزائر كانت راعيه اساسيه
للمفاوضات في عمليه شمال مالي ثم يجب ولا
ننسى ان انصار الدين ربما الايجابيه في
الموضوع ان حركه الوطنيه حير ازواد باع
باعلانها المبدا الاول الاستقلال على دوله
مالي اعتقد انها فتحت فعلا باب الجحيم في
مالي ان انها اولا اخافت العديد من الدول
منها الجزائر وهي حساسه جدا لعمليه
العقليات خاصه الطوارق ويمكن ان تكون هذه
بمثابه يعني كره الثلج في كل المنطقه وفي
نفس الوقت خوف من الحركات الجهاديه
المسلحه الاخرى منها وخاصه القاعده في
بلاد المغرب الاسلامي وبالتالي كان كان
حتما على الجزائر ان تحاول ان تجد اطراف
اخرى من اجل كبح جماح التنظيمات الاخرى
وفي نفس الوقت ان يك يكون لديها على الاقل
وسيله اتصال لكن اذا سمحت هناك نقطه مهمه
وهي قضيه يعني فتح المجال اعتقد انم
الدبلوماسيه الجزائريه ربما يعني وصلت الى
قناعه وهي انه ما دام الحرب الحرب اصبحت
حتميه الان وانه قرار خرج من مجلس الامن
فمن من الاجد ربما تقديم اضعف الايمان اقل
خدمه لانح بين قوسين لفرنسا والمشاركه في
على الاقل في المسار المعلوماتي في عمليه
التخطيط واعتقد ان زياره الرئيس هولند كان
من اسبابها هي اولا ضوء اخضر او ما نسميه
في الدبلوماسيه على قل الحياد الايجابي
للجزائر في هذه العمليه لان بدون الحياد
الايجابي للجزائر من الصعب جدا ان تقوم
هذه العمليه الان اصبحت التبعات التداعيات
خطيره جدا بالاضافه الى تدفق الالاف من
اللاجئين والذين فعلا سيكون عب على كل دول
الجوار بما فيها الجزائر هناك انهاك للقوه
لان التنظيمات المسلحه بعد العمليات
الجويه من المؤكد انها س يعني ستخرج من
مخابئها ومن معاق لها فستت توجه الى اين
الى الحدود الاكثر اتساعا سواء كان في
موريطانيا او الجزائر ولذلك ما اخشاه هو
انهاك عمليه انهاك القوات المسلحه اصلا في
كل دول الجوار والتي هي اصلا منهكه والتي
هي اصلا في عمليات مسلحه دائمه لضبط
الحدود خاصه بعد سقوط نظام القذافي وعجز
الحكومه الليبيه الى حد الساعه لضبط
حدودها هذه نقطه اساسيه وهي انه محاوله
استقرار ليبيا ربما ستخلق بؤر عدم استقرار
في المنطقه اذا لم لم تصاحبها عمليات اخرى
من اجل فعلا تكون المقاربه شامله يعني
اشرت الى نقطه مهمه وضع امني هج تعيش
المنطقه بعد سقوط نظام القذافي في ليبيا
وسهوله انتشار السلاح كما تحدثت تحدثت
الكثير من التقارير عنه في ظل هكذا وضع
واتحول بسؤال هنا للسيد الحسين ولد مدو
يعني ما المطلوب حتى لا يتحول هذا الصراع
في مالي رب ربما الى صراع تتسع وتمتد
رقعته وتطال هذه الدول دول المنطقه
جميعا اعتقد بان الصراع المالي بدات
شرارته تطال كل دول المنطقه هو الصراع
سواء في ابعاده الانسانيه والبشريه كان
الجيران خصوصا دول الميدان هي اول من
اكتوت سواء باستقبال الاف ومئات عشرات
الاف النازحين في موريتانيا او في الجزائر
وسواء باستهداف الجماعات المسلحه ايضا
لهذه البلدان كما حدث في الجزائر لذل اول
من يدفع الضريبه زياده على الابعاد
المدنيه في مالي بصفه عامه والشعوب التي
تعاني القهر والظلم والغبن في منطقه
الشمالي بالنسبه لمالي كانت دول الميدان
سيما الجزائر وسما موريتانيا لذلك اعتقد
بانها بدات تدفع تلك الضريبه والضريبه
ستزداد اكثر سيما وانه بعد مختلف
المباحثات التي جرت سواء ببساطه من
الجزائر و من الفاعلين الدوليين بصفه عامه
حصلت بعض التنزيلات بالمفهوم التجاري من
طرف جماعه انصار الدين وحتى من طرف الحركه
الوطنيه لتحرير ازواد التنازل عن مفهوم
الاستقلال الدوله والتنازل عن مفهوم
التطبيق العام للشريعه على امتداد القطر
المالي قبل ان نفاش بعمليه اثار هذه
الخطوات وتحييد المسار التفاوضي والحواري
واللجوء الىى العمل العسكري بعد مبادره
انصار الدين بالهجوم او التوجه جنوبا لذلك
اعتقد بان اغلب دول هذه المنطقه سما
موريتانيا والجزائر وهذا التخوف الذي
كثيرا ما ابدته بحيال انعكاسات التي
ستطاول المنطقه بعد الحرب هو تخوف وجيه
ويستمد وجهته اساسا من ان وحده الجغرافيا
لا تتحول هؤلاء هم الذين سيبقون في
النهايه سواء في استضافه اللاجئين او سواء
في تلقي كل الضربات من هذا او هذاك نيران
صديقه او نيران غير صديقه والجيوش
الفرنسيه والجيوش المتعلقه بدول غرب
وافريقيا سترحل ان عاجلا اجلا مع ترك
المنطقه ب كبؤره توتر دائمه ا بؤره توتر
دائمه الضريبه بدات تدفع ايضا كما ذكرت
انسانيا تدفق عشرات الاف اللاجئين امنيا
حادثه عيننا مناس لعلها المثال الاوضح
عسكريا كما ذكرت الدكتور حسنين العبيدي
انهاك الجيوش وبالتالي ما افق الحل
باعتقادك ربما لحل هذه
الازمه يعني فرنسا هي بصراحه يعني هذه
الحرب هي حرب الرئيس هولند يعني وهي يعني
حرب وجود كذلك بالنسبه لفرنسا التي لا
يمكن ان تقبل بان منطقه نفوذ اساسيه لها
منطقه مالي والنيجر ولذلك التذكير مصالح
المصالح الحيويه والاقتصاديه في منطقه
اصلا هي منطقه تنافس والولايات المتحده
كما تعلمين كانت لديها خبره في هذه
المنطقه وهي التي اصلا كونت عسكريا العديد
من قيادات الجيش المالي هناك سراع نفوذ
فرنسا تخشى فعلا ان تذهب منها هذه المنطقه
لكن المشكله القضيه الان وهي هذه عقليه
الاستعلاء وعدم الاهتمام باراء الاخرين
ربما ستؤدي بنا الى فعلا وضع حرج جدا ووضع
معقد ويصبح من الصعب حتى على الدول الجوار
التي هي متردده في العمليه العسكريه ان
يعني ان تم تمد يد المساعده القول بان
الحكومه ماليه طلبت مساعده ودول اكواس نحن
نعلم جيدا ما هي مدى هشاشه هذه الحكومات
وعدم شرعيتها لان في النهايه خاصه دكتور
حسني ا فق اعدني افتح قوس صغيره فقط
وساعود اليك خاصه اذا ما علمنا بان من وصل
الى حد الان من القوات الافريقيه الموعوده
ليس سوى 100 جندي من اصل 5000 و 700
الموعوده بها
مالي صحيح يعني نحن الان نحتفل بذكرى
الاحتفال الصداقه الالمانيه الفرنسيه انه
المانيا ف يعني منذ اسبوعين قالت انها
ستبعث طاقم طبي يعني و مفوضيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي اشن الان تقريبا غائبه تماما ف
نحس يعني هناك احساس بان مره اخرى افريقيا
ستدفع
ثمن حسابات لا ليست ليها علاقه مباشره
بالدول الافريقيه وانه مقاربه التفاوض قبل
كل شيء مقاربه تحييد الجماعات المسلحه على
الاهالي ومحاوله اعطاء بعد اقتصادي وبعد
سياسي لهذه المنطقه تم كذلك استبعاده
لمصلحه الحسم العسكري هل فرنسا قادره بعد
خروج التنظيمات المسلحه لتامين واستقرار
مالي من المؤكد لا فكيف يمكن ان هل هل مره
اخرى ستعود وتلعب دور دركي مالي ودركي
افريقيا في النيجر من المؤكد لا لان
المواطن الفرنسي لا غير مستعد ان يدفع هذه
الفاتوره هذه الاسئله من المفروض كانت ان
تبحث قبل ان تتم هذه العمليه التي مره
اخرى تمت باستعجال ا عمليه تمت على عجل
السيد الحسين ولد مدو لكن تبعاتها لكن
تبعاتها الى حد الان يبدو ان شرارتها طالت
مختلف دول المنطقه هل سنصل في مرحله ما
يمكن ان تتغير فيها الاستراتيجيه
الفرنسيه ام لا
باعتقادك اعتقد بان التعوي في هذه الحاله
لن يكون اساسا على فرنسا التي بدات عمليه
التجذير المسار في هذه المنطقه سيكون
اساسا على دول الميدان التي اكتوت اكثر
بهذه النيران والتي ستكون اكثر عمليه
واكثر استعداد ايضا لاحتضان كل الارتكاس
التي ستنشئ عن هذه الحرب واخص بالذكر
خصوصا الجزائر وموريتانيا على هذه الدول
ان تدفع نحو المزيد من تحيد اكبر عدد ممكن
من المدنيين ومحاوله كسب اكبر عدد من
الفرقاء المحليين الى جانب استثمار نقطه
الحوار بين الفرقاء والحكومه الماليه في
ظل مسار واضح يضمن استعاده مالي الشقيقه
لوحدتها ويضمن كذلك تحييد العمل المسلح
ولكن الاستجابه للمطالب المشروعه ما دون
السياده لسكان الشمال بصفه عامه وتلافي
وتجاوز تلك المغارم الكثيره يؤسفني كثيرا
انه من تعقيدات الوضع الحالي ان كل الحرب
ونحن ندخل في اسبوعها الثالث تجري بدون
شهود لحد الان لا وجود للاعلاميين حتى على
لا كاميرا لا صوت لا صوره اذا هي تجري
بدون شهود ولهذا ستكون بكل تاكيد انعكاسات
وخصوصا على البعد المدني وعلى امكانيه
الاختراقات والتجاوزات التي يمكن ان تحدث
بفعل النيران الصديقه او غير الصديقه من
طرف الطيران الفرنسي وعموما اعتقد بان
الحرب في مالي ستكسب على مستوى فرنسا بصفه
عامه مزيدا من تشتيت وتفتيت ما يعرف
بالجماعات المسلحه في في هذه المنطقه ولكن
لعل في تفتيتها عوده الى الل نمطيه التي
كانت احدى اسباب نجاحها ولذلك سنعود من
جديد الى الكره في البدر شكرا جزيلا لك
الحسين ولد مدو والمحلل السياسي كما نشكر
جزيل الشكر ضيفنا من باريس الدكتور حسني
عبيدي مدير مركز الدراسات والابحاث حول
العالم العربي في جناف استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعتي باريس
وجناب ختام هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر السلام
عليكم
ان